ich wünsche mir wirklich dass die
ankündigung von jens sparen das ist zum
ersten märz klappt das alles kostenfrei
genutzt werden
getestet werden können dass es
funktioniert nur ich sag ihnen auch beim
thema impfen haben wir gemerkt können
wir den ankündigung von ihren sparen
nicht glauben da wird jetzt immer weiter
korrigiert und korrigiert die daten
werden nach hinten geschoben und ich
habe ein bisschen angst dass wir die
nächste enttäuschung schaffen also bei
mir im wahlkreis standen die leute schon
auf der matte und wollten wissen wo sie
dann genau am ersten märz sich testen
lassen können das ist für viele ja ganz
wichtig wenn sie zum beispiel zu den
eltern fahren oder wenn sie unterwegs
sind auch beruflich unterwegs
also wo kann man das eigentlich machen
soll und da sind viele fragen die hier
entspannt bis heute überhaupt nicht
beantwortet hat also genau die frage an
andere war und warum trainer
warum treten sie waren freuen sich nach
sind ja der koalitionspartner schön
natürlich drängen wir aber wir haben
jetzt das ist es im kabinett ist ein
cola kabinett da werden diese dinge
besprochen sie haben heute vielleicht
auch das interview von malu dreyer
gelesen die den druck aus den ländern
macht wird machen doch druck aber am
ende ist es doch eine frage auch ob hier
entspannen seine seine politischen
vorhaben per twitter verkündet oder ob
man das auf ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
und ob man das im kabinett ob man das in
der wunde auch mit den
gesundheitsministern der länder macht
und dort dinge ordentlich vorbereitet
und ich erlebe jetzt dass die politik
per twitter gemacht wird und in einer
phase wo wir vertrauen verloren haben
weil es nicht funktioniert da jetzt das
nächste und top zu setzen das läuft eine
große gefahr dass wieder vertrauen
verloren geht und ich wünsche mir dass
hier entspannen das hinkriegt zum ersten
märz es wird nicht daran scheitern dass
die spd nicht unterstützt oder dass wir
nicht ausreichend druck machen aber das
sind noch zehn tage und wir haben gerade
gehört was für eine wahnsinns
infrastruktur aufgebaut werden mussten
ich befürchte es gibt wieder
enttäuschungen am ersten märz